خلونا الاتفاق يمرق يمرق بلدنا يمرقنا لبر
الامان ما دايرين مشاكل
المنابر ويحض السودانيين على الالتزام
بالاتفاق وتاره اخرى يظهر وكانه الذراع
الايمن لرئيس مجلس السياده قائد الجيش عبد
الفتاح البرهان انه نائبه قائد الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان دقلو المعروف بحميتي
اتحدا على الاطاحه بالرئيس المعزول عمر
البشير وبعد عامين طفت على السطح
خلافاتهما وحولت المشهد الى صراع سلطه
وبلادنا اصابها جرح بالغ موقع اكسيوس
الامريكي وصف القتال بينهما بانه اشبه
بمعركه غرور كبلت السودان في هاويه
الصراعات الدمويه ومعها كشف كيف تفجرت
الاوضاع بينهما وحدد الشعره التي قسمت ظهر
الاتفاق الايطالي
اربعه مصادر مطلعه على المفاوضات اكدت ان
نزاعهما اخرج السودان عن المسار
الديمقراطي مرتين حيث تصاعد التوتر سريعا
مع بدء المحادثات ورفضهما الترحيب ببعضهما
او تبادل اي كلمات اعداء ترسخ عندما لم
يتمكن القائدان من ايجاد ارضيه مشتركه
بشان التسلسل القيادي العسكري لاعاده
تنصيب حكومه مدنيه ومن هنا كرت سبحه
الخلافات وانحرف السودان عن مسار انتقاله
الديمقراطي
فالبرهان يريد ان يكون الشخصيه العسكريه
العليا والوحيده التي تقدم تقاريرها
مباشره الى الحكومه المدنيه وكذلك احمدتي
يسعى الى ان تكون له قناه لا تمر عبر قائد
الجيش ولم يتفق على اليه تقاسم السلطه بين
الجنرالين والتي من شانها ان تمنح كلا
منهما حقا نقضي على القرارات
اما ارسال قوه الدعم السريع الى القاعده
الجويه والى الخرطوم كان فارقا واستفزازا
صريحا بالنسبه للجيش السوداني ومعه نسفت
امال ايجاد حل عبر الحوار خاصه وان حجم
الهوه بينهما يؤكد اللاصقه من اصلها بين
الجانبين اللذين جعل السودان رهينه
لخلافاتهما بحسب الموقع ما يجعل اقناع
الرجلين بوقف القتال بعيد المنال الا مع
اعلان احدهما النصر ببساطه وصل الى نقطه
لا عوده في تلك العلاقه اسراء الصغير
العربيه